- Les Torontois l'ont attendu
défilé de la Fierté gaie est
de retour dans la mépopopopopour
la première fois depuis le début
de se rassembler et de se dire :
"Bonjour. Wow! Vous êtes encore
là? Vous nous avez manqué!",bib.
Pour d'autres, comme ce père
de famille qui a récemment
annoncé son homosexualité,énénét
une première.
- J'avais pe
d'être moi-même. C'est stupide!
OK, c'est vrtututututupide!
T'as juste une vie! Vis-la, OK?
Il faut la vivre... la vivre
avec amour.
- Près de 2 millions de
les rues de la ville, dimanche,
pour les festivités.
Une occasion en or pour
et pour la ville, qui souhaite
relancer son économie.
JOHN TORY, maire de Torontoauau,
les magasins sont pleins,
les hôtels sont pleins et c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour tout
l'économie et pour toutlelelelet
que le dispositif de sécurit
a été renforcé cette année,
en raison des menaces auxquellc+
dans le monde.
Les détecteurs de métal ont
par exemple proche des scènes d.
Le directeur générale e e e e er
prit cette décision avant
la fusillade survenue à Oslo,
en Norvège, samedi,elelelelelel,
le drame confirme toutefois
la nécessité d'accroître
la sécurit
"Le festival est plus qu
célébration, dit-il. Il s'agit
rappeler que beaucoup de membres
de la communauté LGBTQ+
ne peuvent toujours pas vivre
"Cela me fait chaud au coeur
d'être dans un pays où être ga
est normalisé. Dans mon pays,
ils viennent d'invalider
et maintenant, ils vont
s'attaquer au mariage gai,
déplore ce festivalier
Cette année, les organisateurs
du fononononont misé sur
les talents locaux. En tout,
plus de 300 artistes ont pris
de 275 originaires de la région
de Toronto.
Ici Andréane Williams